Tsar Nicholas ii gave this beautiful egg
to his consort 100 years ago to mark the
300th anniversary of the Romanov dynasty
the Faberge egg is part of the Romanov
horde the treasures and symbols of a
family that made Russia great and
influenced European history for
centuries
Paul Edward kulakowski is a descendant
of the dynasty a great-great grandson of
Tsar Alexander the third oh I feel a lot
of pride I'm very happy to see this it's
amazing to see all these beautiful
artifacts not only are they beautiful in
the sense of artwork but also the the
spirituality of these items the emotion
that they gave me and of course they're
related to to my family so for me sort
of family history so for me it's a great
joy just to walk through here Moscow is
the city where the Tsar's were crowned
but the Romanovs history started in
kostroma
several hundred kilometers to the north
Yevgeniy culligan organizes a festival
every year here he's recounting the
story for some Swiss visitors it was in
the impassive monastery that Mikhail
feodorovich was elected as the first
Roman Afsar at the time Russia was being
torn apart by Civil War and foreign
invaders the Romanovs used cunning skill
and brute force to make Russia stable
and powerful that ascent began in Costa
Roma so you get a good sense of how much
happened here you can feel this long
family history this long dynasty that a
lot of important decisions were made
here cos drama thrived as the young
Russian Empire expanded the city became
one of its most important centres of
commercial and cultural activity but
Kostroma is not just about the past
Yevgeniy culligan and a team of friends
set up an art project called stanza
meaning station in a former factory
once a year he invites artists from
across Europe to take part in a dance
festival
dinasty Romano Catherine the grade and
Peter the Great and the other Romanovs
always had an open european view of
everything new and progressive modern
art is always progressive I think the
Czar's would have liked what we're doing
here today the Czar's heritage plays
only a minor role in Costa Roma and
Moscow is paying little attention to the
Romanov anniversary
but the treasures of the Kremlin's speak
for themselves and there's still a lot
of important artifacts in the diamond
fund which of course is also in the
Moscow Kremlin but they are not really
part of this exhibition so actually
there is a fourth place here in the
Moscow Kremlin that you have to go to
even though it's not officially part of
the exhibition it would have been nice
to see all the crowns just lying next to
each other so you could see them sort of
in a quick sequence but Paul kulakowski
is just glad that so many czars treasure
survived the Russian Revolution and the
Soviet era
they'll be on display at the Kremlin
until the end of January